can you guys remember the last time a
company announced a new console through
an exclusive interview that only talked
about some of the details I don't think
I'm old enough no like not I mean this
seems like it's the way they do it of
like hey here's mark Cerny talking to
you about the guts or whatever like
there there's a little bit a little bit
of that like around the PlayStation 4 I
think they've they had something with
him but did we already know that like a
ps4 was coming and they already sort of
like discussed it a little bit cuz this
seems like it obviously came out of
nowhere for a lot of us right it's so
casual that I'm sort of taken aback yeah
it's it it looks casual and you wonder
like how hard do they all work to make
it seem very casual to announce this
hours before Microsoft is set to
announce stuff that is like not next-gen
platform related true like it's kind of
weird I wonder if they just got tired of
like Google and you know Microsoft's
been talking about next-gen stuff for
like a year now right with you three
coming into being there either yeah if
they're just like well we need to pick a
shot here
let's just go yeah cuz stuff did not go
her so so no really cared no well I I
cared in that I couldn't change my name
because I was verified let's jump
through a bunch of Hoops change my name
won't realize that all the good names
are taken yeah which is a problem yeah
it's wired yeah I'm trying to think like
because there was always some early
stuff for like Microsoft gave digital
foundry some stuff over that was like
like early on the Xbox one they brought
them into air facilities they give them
a tour of life different prototypes and
stuff so there's that but this is like I
mean you you knew they were working on
another piece of hardware they had said
that much but yeah you know it'll be
backwards compatible of course and yeah
definitely have a disk drive yeah
there's a lot of a lot of love juicy
stuff there's way more detail yeah but
they just oh here's why cuz the thing
with digital foundries like we're gonna
we already know the one X coming but
we're gonna let lay down like some of
the technical like performance and stuff
so because that's kind of what they do
so here it's like oh yeah of course
PS 5 is coming but there's still a room
for for them to have a big announcement
like ok y'all know that the PS 5 has got
this a snap
let's have a they can still have a big
conference with a show like the piece of
hardware and they lay out like a lineup
of here's like some launch games here
the games that are like gonna be on ps4
and am PS 5 because that's the thing too
is that mark centre you kind of like
when they talk about that stranding it's
kind of like oh that's a ps4 game right
yeah it's like PS 5 like I don't know
always being a little cheeky according
to that articles but I mean of course
that's gonna happen in those those
intergenerational games definitely big
backwards compatible with ps4 games you
start to wonder then we start to see
something sort of like the pro where you
have ps4 games that run a little bit
better on a PS 5 oh yeah and then also
maybe some of them get proper native PS
5 versions but maybe some of them don't
right where they're just like ok you can
get true 4k none this checkerboard stuff
if you're on a PS 5 but you know might
be you might not you've said showing but
I have to imagine like in the PC space
right when you have just like tech that
scales year after year it's also based a
similar foundation yeah games can just
have settings that that tweak things you
know naming and obviously requires
developers to balance for that sort of
thing when it comes to performance but I
would almost have to imagine that the
PlayStation 5 will play ps4 games in
higher fidelity to a degree yeah and in
a way you think about it because I think
this may have been the first time at
least for Sony where the jump in
generation is more or less the same
architecture based on what we know yeah
because you know coming off of cell then
going to ps4 was like oh sell was a
nightmare so now we're have this x86
based piece of hardware like here's what
developers like to develop on turns out
so if that is a thing that they're gonna
do i Majan it's gonna be a lot easier
than it has been in the past for super
games we they have to have that top of
mind yeah you mentioned developers have
been asking for one of the things that
article highlighted was SSDs right and I
think for a lot of us we always assume
that just means like oh yeah it's
quieter and it'll load games a little
bit faster but some of the examples they
were laying out there were kind of
insane to me like the idea of the Spider
Man fast travel going it from 15 seconds
to half a second or something like that
yeah and it's not only because it's an
SSD it's because like the the data bus
that they're using for their SSD is
apparently faster than anything
available on the PC side right now which
is kind of nice I guess so I mean they
would probably have either be using
- and Remy which is like the top of the
line right now ah I see if they can be
doing that stuff is expensive
though and you know even for PC gamers
like that's still something that is a
luxury not necessarily something you
always get when you build a new PC so
that's an impressive thing to hear
because yeah it's like you can slap an
SSD into like a ps4 and it's gonna maybe
make you a little times faster but like
not at that rate it not the way it works
on a PC exactly either yeah like that's
what it was
monster underworlds like a really good
example like look at those load-times on
ps4 and then on a PC with an SSD yeah
like it's not half a second fast but
it's still just like boom comparison
yeah I guess retracing is the other kind
of big technical thing that they dropped
which Nvidia just sort of they opened up
to their previous line of GPUs yes which
makes that conversation a bit more
interesting because up until now it was
really relegated to their new 20 line
yeah RTX cards yeah I guess I was
surprised by the fact that you know AMD
is still building the guts of this
console so it's gonna be next-gen rise
in it's gonna be their next gen GPU
architecture but AMD hasn't they haven't
done rate racing yet right it's all been
in in videos kind of space with the RT X
cards and like you mentioned they they
brought it over to their previous
generation but it's very like retracing
is now like a spectrums we're like oh I
can have reflections but that many
reflections if I want a weaker card or I
could have the whole thing with like
global illumination and all that if you
have like the RT X cores in your GPU so
that's another thing too is that RT X
cards on NVIDIA side can do that stuff
because they have a dedicated core to
take care of all that processing right
because that stuff is intensive so
totally I mean when they say like oh
it's gonna have ray tracing like to what
degree of course it's not just like
Rachel seem you slap it on yeah it's
like I'm it's my amateur brain way of
thinking it's like a multi step vector
calculation yes you only go so many
steps before you run out of power to do
that but that's sacrificing frame rate
yeah but do they were also talking about
audio being a big thing and Rachel
you're saying can also play a part in
that to help sort of calculate spatial
audio like he said specifically what are
the things I'm really disappointed in
from
three to four is that there was no
advancement in audio tech yeah that that
was notable to the user it sounds like
that's gonna be a really big thing for
them and he said the gold standard will
be headphones which maybe isn't a
surprise to many people who play games
and take audio seriously but to hear him
say that is kind of fascinating I like
my home theater yeah you know I want to
I want to shake the walls that's that's
what I'm into so yeah I don't know
headphones aren't really my thing
but at the same time I think the example
they give of like hey here's another way
that movie you know some of the
ray-tracing stuff can be used for more
than just like hey the Lighting's good
yeah the idea of just like using it to
have more realistic audio I think that's
cool the more stuff you can kind of do
in a physics sort of sense you know it
means that more developers have access
to doing things like that because they
don't have to spend a bunch of time
either making it in or they're spending
much time on the audio if they can just
kind of say like okay well it's in the
engine we can just do it yeah I think
that's kind of cool
yeah I hadn't really thought about until
I read the article like oh yeah audio
hasn't really changed all that much I
guess we don't use sound cards anymore
for our pcs right unless we're like
extra bougie or something want to ball
out on a sound card but no one really
does that anymore and the thing to like
virtual 3d audio is a thing but I mean
of course that's not organic I guess you
can say it's all I guess faked so if
there is like a way to to like the
ray-tracing techniques for audio like I
want to hear that I want to know what
that sounds like
yeah yeah I think what he mentioned like
lastly that there's something they're
not talking about that is like the
game-changing feature of the console
interactive tech right we've seen
companies do that like Microsoft and it
not really work like what they connect
like I mean I guess I worked for
Nintendo you know with the free yeah but
it's like I don't know it depends on
your definition of just like what
actually is this like game-changing sort
of thing well it's also marketing right
yeah yeah yeah well think about the was
the the patent they had about they're
putting your friends in the audience of
different ways to do emulation or
different ways to have access to older
games and older platforms and stuff like
that whole I think if you line that up
with where they're at
and they've already said hey it'll play
PlayStation 4 games maybe they go
further that would be awesome
and and I think that's that's kind of
what that patent I think was getting at
when I was looking at that it seemed
like okay this maybe this is gonna do
more than just play ps4 and PS five
games but you know at the same time Sony
was out there beating the drum all along
about like God no one really cares about
backwards compatibility mainly because
they're not doing it and Microsoft was
yeah they couldn't totally do a 180 on
that though oh yeah like in classic
consoles aren't the way to go I guess
especially the Sony yeah they tried it
yeah kind of screw that one up no I
don't know I guess they would they
wouldn't go down that route anymore if
they want to introduce their older
lineups right so maybe have something
like that they also kind of allude to
just like well it's not so much an
illusion it's like he says hey we're
pioneers in the cloud gaming space we're
an accurate you know they believed they
bought Gaikai they integrated all that
stuff in a PlayStation now but it's not
great and you don't get the impression
that they have invested in a cloud
infrastructure in the same way yeah you
know it was on Google Microsoft the way
that those kind of players have and
there's the potential for cloud gaming
cloud streaming whatever we're calling
it now like in regards to something like
what Google is doing it doesn't
necessarily have to be like that I have
to imagine there are probably ways that
Sony could or anyone could use that
concept and break it out sort of like
with ray-tracing right doing something
unexpected that we didn't really know
about like off put some of that
processing power kind of like what maybe
I guess what Microsoft is whether you're
getting in a crackdown territory and
maybe maybe Sony could be the one to
actually like pull that off where you
have both a game running locally and
yeah I mean it comes up to the creation
behind that game yeah developers I think
Microsoft was just kind of the way I
keep saying is just Trojan horsing like
an example yeah rather than saying like
because they were not like check this
[ __ ] out this is the hotness we've
figured it this out they kind of slipped
it in yeah I feel you yeah you know they
said that the PlayStation VR will be
backwards compatible as well which means
that
you could hook a camera up that thing I
would love to see them do an updated
head set that has been adding get rid of
those Move controllers once and for all
and get something that actually works
yeah I'd also want to see inside out
tracking because the PlayStation camera
is not it yeah so yeah hopefully they do
something along those lines just to kind
of improve the fidelity of that
experience and especially if they have
more power driving it like you could
start to see like oh they're building a
case for what maybe you do a higher
resolution headset yeah or something
like that to buddy but I don't know that
that really falls into this category of
just like here's this game-changer we're
not announcing yeah I wouldn't think so
yeah I think it's a little ambiguous but
up but Sarnia I think his name was on
that backwards compatibility patent
stuff so maybe that's his baby
that'd be great so yeah now they think
about it is when you know Sony came out
said like all we're doing we're going
all in on like the local hardware I kind
of see it as at first I would think that
Sony's gonna follow everyone else with
what they're doing with you know
Microsoft doing project X cloud and then
you know they're gonna announce a disk
disk like a this list Xbox real soon and
then Google stadia is gonna make a
splash I guess when it comes around this
year so then now that they've said that
now we're going all in with a with a
really powerful box it's kind of like ok
now they can kind of carve out that
space and because there's a lot of
people who still want that stuff yeah so
if you think about it sets them up for a
similar thing that they were able to do
around the early PlayStation 4 days when
Microsoft was out there with they're
always online stuff and and you know
Sony was able to just drop a video of
someone handing a disc to someone else
like word
Thanks you know if Microsoft pushes too
hard into the cloud stuff and obviously
that's all Google is you know Sony can
just as easily going hey just I can put
an app works yeah after it patches but
you know they can at least say like hey
you know we we value you the existing
player we're not just going after this
like 2 billion though you know however
many other people they can get when they
start you know let you Street with the
phone what if streaming can somehow get
ahead of having to download patches and
stuff like that yeah I think that'd be
cool to me I think streaming and the
cloud stuff is really valuable for demos
I think that would be really cool but
also yeah hey if you are installing the
game or if you've pre-loaded it or
pre-purchased we're gonna let you stream
the first hour of it instead of
downloaded or something like that
there's a lot of kind of hybrid
solutions that but I think every mole
Microsoft would be smart to get into
that sort of thing - I think yeah
Microsoft is seemingly getting in bed
with Nintendo right sure so I guess back
to your point like there everyone's kind
of setting themselves up to have this
identity like Microsoft is gonna be the
friendly I don't know I don't know I
don't know what to call them but like
the we got beat real bad last yeah it's
gonna be nice with everybody yeah I love
the players it's forming a damn a lion's
s and that's yeah that's seem to be
working for whatever that's worth so
yeah and then you know Google's just got
money and racks racks and racks like an
apple as well they're doing they're
kicking yeah they're gonna fun games
that way and get their timed exclusives
on phones yeah I think like you're
starting to see the battle lines to be
drawn for what we're gonna be looking at
for the next few years here and I think
more than normal it seems like
everyone's got a slightly different take
on things as opposed to just like
Microsoft and Sony being basically the
same thing
it feels like fundamentally different
this time out and I don't know it's
interesting to see like actual different
visions for how the next five to ten
years should go I don't know what the
right answer is which is which is kind
of exciting yeah
[Music]